when you're the world's richest man
there is a license of sorts to buy what
you want and behave unpredictably
in this elon musk is a master
he has businesses from space to
supercars he now wants social media he's
made an offer to buy twitter
his confirmation looked like this a
simple tweet just 10 days after he
announced he's now the firm's biggest
shareholder
in a letter to the chairman he said i
invested in twitter as i believe in its
potential to be the platform for free
speech around the globe however since
making my investment i now realize the
company will neither thrive nor serve
this societal imperative in its current
form twitter needs to be transformed as
a private company twitter has
extraordinary potential
i will unlock it
there were signs he rejected an offer to
join the board this week and shared
tweets like these questions like is
twitter dying and poles poking fun at
the culture some say he's driven too by
the censorship debate rouse over what
and who should be restricted
yeah uh elon's got a fairly libertarian
streak and he describes himself as a
free speech absolutist and as we've seen
he
has a habit of tweeting things that
other ceos probably wouldn't and
i think that he has strong feelings
about how twitter should
behave towards
you know speech in general
there's no doubt this leaves twitter in
a very tricky position elon musk has
offered over 54 a share much higher than
what the price was before his
involvement was announced he's also said
he'd withdraw his shareholding if he's
rebuffed if twitter rejects the offer
the share price will likely tank but if
it accepts there could well be a major
overhaul at the top and major changes to
the culture
others say it's a good opportunity for
musk and for twitter
i think one of the most important kind
of
subtexts here
is that twitter hasn't changed all that
much
over the course of its time as a public
company and i think a lot of people were
really desirous of seeing you know much
more in the way of innovation cargo
dragon take flight
there are those who have called this
another vanity project for a man too
rich and too powerful the eyes of the
tech world are all on its most enigmatic
character helen and smith skinnies